The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at OCW.mit.edu.
LORENZO ROSASCO:
I'm Lorenzo Rosasco.
This is going to be a couple
of hours plus of basic machine
learning.
OK.
And I want to emphasize
a bit, the word, "basic."
Because really I
tried to just stick
to the essentials, or
things that I would think
of essentials to just start.
Suppose that you have zero
knowledge of machine learning
and you just want
to start from zero.
OK.
So if you already had
classes in machine learning,
you might find this a little
bit boring or at least
kind of rehearsing things
that you already know.
The idea of looking at
machine learning these days
is coming from at least
two different perspectives.
The first one is for those
of you, probably most of that
are interested to develop
intelligent systems in a very
broad sense.
What happened in
the last few years
is that there's been a kind
of data-driven revolution
where systems that are
trained rather than programmed
start to be the key
engines to solve tasks.
And here, there are just some
pictures that are probably
outdated, like robotics.
You know, we have
Siri on our phone.
We hear about self-driving cars.
In all these systems,
one key engine
is providing data to the
system to essentially try
to learn how to solve the task.
And so one idea of this
class is to try to see
what does it mean to learn?
And the moment that
you start to use
data to solve complex
tasks, then there
is a natural
connection with what
today is called data
science, which is somewhat
a rapid [INAUDIBLE]
renovated version of what we
used to call just statistics.
So basically, we start to have
tons of data of all kinds.
They are very easy
to collect, and we
are starving for knowledge and
trying to extract information
from these data.
And as it turns out,
many of the techniques
that are used to develop
intelligent systems
are the same very
technique that you
can use to try to extract
relevant information
patterns, data, from your data.
So what we want
to do today is try
to see a bit what's
in the middle.
What is the set of techniques
that allows you, indeed,
to go from data to knowledge
or to acquiring ability
to solve tasks.
Machine learning
is huge these days,
and there are tons of
possible applications.
There has been theory
developed in the last 20,
30 years that brought the field
to a certain level of maturity
from a mathematical
point of view.
There have been tons
and tons and tons
of algorithms developed.
OK.
So in three hours,
there is no way
I could give you even
just a little view of what
machine learning is these days.
So what I did is
pretty much this.
I don't know if
you've ever done this,
but you used to do
the mixtape, and you
try to pick the songs that
you would bring with yourself
on a desert island.
That's kind of the way
I thought about what
to put in this one
[INAUDIBLE] lights that we're
going to show in a minute.
So basically, I
thought, what are
those three, four, five
learning algorithms
that you should
know, OK, if you know
nothing about machine learning.
And this is more or
less at least one part.
Of course there are
a few songs that
stayed out of the compilation,
but this is like one selection.
OK.
So as such, we're going
to start, as I said--
whoop-- simple.
And the idea is that
this morning you're
going to see a few algorithms.
And I picked algorithms
that are relatively
simple from a computational
point of view.
So the math level is
going to be pretty basic.
OK.
I think I'm going to
use some linear algebra
at some point and maybe some
calculus, but that's about it.
So most of the idea
here is to emphasize
conceptual ideas, the concepts.
And then today, afternoon,
there's going to be,
basically labs where
you sit and you just
pick these kind of
algorithms and use them,
so you immediately
see, what does it mean?
OK.
So at the end of
the day, you should
have reasonable
knowledge about whatever
you're seeing this morning.
So this is how the
class is structured.
It's divided in
parts plus the lab.
So the first part,
what we want to do
is start from probably the
simplest learning algorithm
you can think of to try
to emphasize, and use
that as an excuse to introduce
the idea of bias-variance,
trade-off, which, to me,
is probably either the,
or one of the most fundamental
concepts in statistics
and machine learning, which
is this idea that you're
going to see in a few
minutes in more detail.
But it's essentially
the idea that you never
have enough data.
OK.
And the game here is not
about describing the data
that you have today,
as much as using
the data you have today
as a basis of knowledge
to describe data you're
going to get tomorrow.
So there is this
inherent trade-off
between what you
have at disposal
and what would you
like to predict.
And then, essentially
it turns out
that you have to somewhat
decide how much you want
to trust the data, and how
much you want to somewhat throw
away, or regularize,
as they say,
smooth out the
information in your data,
because you think that
it's actually an accident.
It's just because you saw
data with aspects today
that are not really reflective
of the phenomenon that
produced them.
But it's just because I saw
10 points rather than 100.
The basic idea
here is essentially
the law of large numbers.
When you toss a coin,
you might find out
that if you toss
it just 10 times,
it looks like it's
not a fair coin,
but if you go for
100, or 1,000, you
start to see that it
converts to 50-50.
OK.
So that's kind of
what's going on here.
So the idea is that you want
to use some kind of induction
principle that tells you how
much you can trust the data.
Moving on from this basic
class of algorithms,
we're going to consider
so-called regularization
techniques.
I use regularization in
a very broad sentence.
And here we're going to
concentrate on least squares
essentially because
A, it's simple,
and it just reduces
to linear algebra.
And so you don't have to
know anything about convex
optimization or any other
kind of fancy optimization
techniques.
And B, because it's
relatively simple
to move from linear models
to non-parametric non-linear
models using kernels.
OK.
And kernels are a big
field with a lot of math,
but you're just
going to look more
at the recipe to move
from simple models
to complicated models.
So finally, the last part,
we're going to move a bit away
from pure prediction.
So basically these
first two parts
are about prediction, or what
is called supervised learning.
And here we're going to move
a bit away from prediction
and we're going to ask questions
more related to, you have data,
and you want to know, what
are the important sectors
in your data?
So the one key word here
is interoperability.
You want to have some form of
interoperability of the data
at hand.
You would like to
know, not only how
you can make good
predictions, but what
are the important sectors.
So you not only want
to do good prediction,
but you want to know how
you make good prediction.
What is the important
information to actually get
good prediction.
And so, in this last part we're
going to take a peek into this.
And as I said, the
afternoon is basically
going to be a practical session.
If it's all MATLAB I think
there is some quick--
if you have never
seen MATLAB before,
you can play around
with just a little bit.
But it's very easy
and then you've
got a few different proposals
I think, of things you can do.
And you can pick, depending on
what you already know and what
you can try, you can start from
that and be more or less fancy.
OK.
So it goes without
saying, stop me.
I mean, the more we
interact, the better it is.
So the first part,
as I said, the idea
is to use so-called local
methods as an excuse
to understand it by experience.
OK.
So we're going to introduce
the simplest algorithm
you can think of, and we're
going to use it to understand
a much deeper concept.
So first of all, let's
just put down our setup.
The idea is that we are--
so how many of you had a
machine learning class before?
All right.
So, you won't be too bored.
The idea is we want to
do supervised learning.
So in supervised learning there
is an input and an output.
And these inputs and outputs
are somewhat related.
And I'll be more
precise in a minute.
But the idea is that
you want to learn
this input-output relationship.
And all you have at disposal
are sets of inputs and outputs.
OK.
So x here is an input,
and y is the output.
f is a functional
relation between the input
and the output.
All you have in this puzzle
are these couples, OK.
So I give an input,
and then what's
the corresponding output?
I give another input
and I know what's
the corresponding output.
But I don't give
you all of them.
You just have n, OK. n
is the number of points,
and you call this
a training set,
because it will be the basis
of knowledge in which you
can try to train a machine
to estimate this functional
relationship.
OK.
And the key point here
is that, on the one hand,
you want to describe these data.
So you want to get a
functional relationship that
works well that, if
you get the next one
to give you an f(x1), which
is close to y1 and so on.
And f(x2), which is close to y2.
But more importantly,
you want an f, that
given a new point
that was not here,
will give you an
output, which is
a good estimate
of the true output
to correspond to that input.
OK.
This is the most important
thing of the setup.
OK.
The ideal, so-called
generalization,
if you want prediction.
If you want to
really do inference.
You don't want to do
descriptive statistics.
You really want to do
inferential statistics.
So this is just very,
very simple example,
but just to start to
have something in mind.
Suppose that you have--
well, it's just like a toy
version of the face recognition
system we have on our phones.
You know that when you
take a picture, you start--
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
LORENZO ROSASCO: They
really weren't talking.
You have something like this.
You have a little square
appearing around a face
sometimes.
It means that basically
the system is actually
going inside the image
and recognizing faces.
OK.
So the idea is a bit more
complicated than this.
But a toy version
of this algorithm
is, you have an image like this.
OK.
The image you think of
as a matrix of numbers.
Now this is color, but imagine
it's black and white, OK.
Then it would just
contain a number,
which is the pixel value
with the light intensity
of that pixel.
And you just have this array.
And then if you want you can
brutalize it with and just
unroll the matrix
into a long vector.
OK.
That gives one vector.
So p here would be what?
The number of?
Just the number of pixels.
OK.
So I take this image
and I unroll it.
I take another image
And I take images.
And you see, some images
here do contain faces.
Some of the images
do not contain faces.
OK.
And I here use
color to code them.
And now what I have is that
images are my inputs, OK,
are the x's.
So here-- full
disclosure, I never use
the little arrow above
letters to denote vectors.
So hopefully it will be
clear from the context.
When it's really useful I
use upper or lower indices.
Anyway.
So this is the data matrix.
Rows are inputs and columns
are so-called features
or variables, are the
entries of each vector.
OK.
And I have n rows and p columns.
Associated to this, I
have my output vector.
And what is the output vector?
Well in this case, it's
just a simple binary vector.
And the idea here is, if
there is a face, I put 1.
If there is not a
face, I put minus 1.
OK.
So this is the way I turn,
like an abstract question,
recognize faces in
images, into some data
structure that in a minute
we're going to elaborate
to try to actually
answer the question,
whether there is a face
in an image or not.
OK.
So this first step, it's
kind of obvious in this case,
but it's actually a tricky step.
OK.
It's the part that I'm not going
to give you any hint about.
It's kind of an art.
You have data and you have--
at the very beginning
you have to turn them
into some kind of
manageable data structure.
OK.
Then you can elaborate
in multiple ways.
But the very first step is
you deciding-- for example,
here we decided to unroll all
these numbers into vectors.
This sounds like a good
idea or a bad idea?
One thing that you're
doing is that the pixel
here and the pixel here
are probably related.
And in this case there is
some structure in the image.
And so when you take this
pixel 136, and you unroll it,
it comes here.
So they're not close.
OK.
Now here it turns out that
if you think about it--
you'll see a minute.
For those of you who
remember, if you just
took Euclidean distance,
you take product of numbers
and you sum them up.
That's invariant to the position
of the individual pixels.
So that's OK.
OK.
But yet again, there is
this intuition that, well,
maybe here I'm losing too
much geometric information
about the context of the image.
And indeed, while this
kind of works in practice,
but if you want to
get better results
you have to do the fancy
stuff that Andrei was talking
about today, looking locally
and try to look at collection,
try to keep more
geometric information.
OK.
So I'm not going to talk
about that kind of stuff.
This up to date, a lot of
engineering, and some good way
to learn it.
But we're going to
try to just stick
to simple representations.
OK.
So how do you build
representation is now
going to be part of what
I'm going to talk about.
So imagine that
either and you stick
to this super-simple
representation or some friends
of yours come in
and put the box here
in the middle, where you
put this array of numbers
and you extract another
vector much fancier than this
that contains some better
representation of an image.
OK.
But then at the end
of the day, my job
starts when you give me
a vector representation
that I can trust.
And I can basically say that
if two vectors seem similar,
they should have the same label.
And that's the basic idea.
OK.
All right.
So a little game
here is, OK, imagine
that these are just the
two-pixel version of the images
I showed you before.
You have some
boxes, some circles.
And then I give you
this one triangle.
It's very original.
Andrei showed you
this yesterday.
And the question is,
what's the color of that?
OK.
Unless you haven't
slept a minute,
you're going to say it's orange.
But the question is, why
do you think it's orange?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LORENZO ROSASCO: Say it again?
AUDIENCE: It's
surrounded by oranges.
LORENZO ROSASCO: It's
OK.
And she said, it's
close to oranges.
So it turns out that this
is actually the simplest
algorithm you can think of.
OK.
You check who you have close
to you, and if it's orange,
you say orange.
And if it's blue, you say blue.
OK.
But we already made
an assumption here,
which we ask in the question,
which is the nearby things.
So we are basically saying that
our of vectoral representation
is such that, if two
things are close--
so I do have a distance,
and if two things are close,
then they might have the
same semantic content.
OK.
Which might be true or not.
For example, if you take
this thing I showed you here,
we cannot just draw it, right?
We cannot just take 200 times
200 vectors and just look
at them and say, yeah, you
know, a visual inspection.
You have to believe that
this distance will be fine.
And so the discussion that
we just had about what
is a good representation
is going to kick in.
OK.
But the assumption you make--
in this case visually it's
very easy, it's low dimension--
is that nearby things
have similar labels.
One thing that I forgot to tell
you in the previous slides,
but it's key, is
exactly this observation
that in machine learning
we typically move away
from situations
like this one, where
you can do visual inspection
and you have low dimensionality,
to kind of a situation like
the one I just showed you
a minute before,
where you have images.
And if you have to think of each
of these circles as an image,
you want to be able to
draw it, because it's
going to be several
hundred typically,
or tens dimensional vector.
OK.
So the game is
kind of different.
Can we still do
this kind of stuff?
Can we just say that
closed things should
have the same semantic content?
That's another question
we're going to try to answer.
OK.
But I just want to do
a bit of inception.
This is a big deal, OK,
going from low dimension
to very high dimensions.
All right.
But let's stick for
a minute to the idea
that nearby things should
have the same label,
and just write the one line,
write down the algorithm.
It's the kind of case where
it's harder to write it down
than to code it up or
just explain what it is.
It's super simple.
What you do is, you
have data points, Xi.
So Xi is the training set, the
input data in the training set.
X-bar is what I
call X-new before.
It's a new point.
What you do is that you search.
This just says, look for the
index of the closest point.
That's what you did before.
OK.
So here, I-prime is the index of
the point Xi closest to X-bar.
Once you find it,
go in your dataset
and find the label
of that point.
And then assign that
label to the new point.
Does that makes sense?
Everybody's happy?
Not super-complicated.
Fair enough.
How does it work?
So let me see if I can do this.
This is extremely fancy code.
Let's see.
All right.
So what did I do?
Let me do it a bit smaller.
So this is just simple
two-dimensional datasets.
I take 40 points.
The dataset looks like this.
The dataset is the
one on the left.
OK.
And what I do, I take 40 points.
And to make it a
bit more complex,
I flip some of the labels.
OK.
So you basically
say that the two
datasets-- this is called
the two moons dataset,
or something like this.
And what I did is that some
of the labels in this sea,
I changed color.
I changed the label.
OK.
So I made the
problem a bit harder.
And here is what fortunately
you don't have in practice.
OK.
Here we're cheating.
We're doing just
the simulations.
We're looking at the future.
We assume that because we
can generate this data,
we can look at the future
and check how we're
going to do in future data.
So you can think of
this as a future data
that typically you don't have.
So here you're a
normal human being.
Here you're playing god
and looking at the future.
OK.
Because we just want to
do a little simulation.
So based on that, we can just
go here and put 1, train,
and then test and plot.
So what you see here is the
so-called decision boundary.
OK.
What I did is exactly that one
line of code you saw before.
OK.
And what I did is, in
this case I can draw it,
because it's low dimensional.
And basically what I do is
that I just put in the regions
where I think I
should put orange,
and the region where it
think I should put blue.
OK.
And here you can kind
of see what's going on.
These are actually very
good on the data, right?
How many mistakes do you
make on the new dataset?
Sorry, on the training set?
Zero.
It's perfect.
OK.
Is that a good idea?
Well, when you look at it here,
it doesn't look that good.
OK.
There is this whole
region of points,
for example, that are going
to be predicted to be orange,
but they're actually blue.
Of course if you want to have
zero errors in the training
set, there's nothing
else you can do, right?
Because you see, you have
this orange point here.
You have these two
orange points here.
And you want to go
and follow them.
So there's nothing you can do.
So this is the
first observation.
The second observation
is, the curve,
if you look close enough,
it's piecewise linear.
It's like a sequence of
linear pieces stuck together.
If we just try to
do a little game
and generate some new data--
OK, so imagine again,
I'm playing god now.
I generate the new dataset
that it should look like.
So take another peek at this.
OK.
Oop.
So now I generate them.
I plot them.
I train.
And now let's test.
OK.
If you remember the decision
curves you've seen before,
what do you notice here?
AUDIENCE: they're different
LORENZO ROSASCO:
They're very different.
OK.
For example, the one
before, if you remember,
we noticed it was going all
the way down here to follow
those couple of points.
But here you don't have
OK.
So now, is that a good
thing or a bad thing?
Well the point here
is that because you
have so few points, the
moment you start to just feed
the data, this will happen.
OK.
You have something that
changes all the time.
It's very unstable.
That's a key word, OK.
You have something
that you change
the data just a little bit,
and it changes completely.
That sounds like a bad idea.
OK.
If I want to make
a prediction, if I
keep on getting
slightly different data
and I change my mind
completely, that's
probably not a good way to make
a prediction about anything.
OK.
And this is happening
all the time here.
And it's exactly
because our algorithm
is in some sense is greedy.
You just try to get
perfect performance
on the training set without
worrying much about the future.
Let's do this just once more.
OK.
And we keep on going.
It's going to change all
the time, all the time.
Of course-- I
don't know how much
I can push this because
it's not super-duper fast.
But let's try.
Let's say 18 by 30.
So what I did now is just that
I augmented the number of points
in my training set.
It was 20 or 30,
I don't remember.
Now it make it 100.
So now you should see--
OK.
So this is one solution.
We want to play the same game.
We just want to generate
other datasets of the same.
So maybe now it might
be that I took them all.
I don't remember
how many there are.
No, I didn't take them all.
So, what do you see now?
We are doing exactly
the same thing.
OK.
And is this something that
you can absolutely not to do
in practice, because you
cannot just generate datasets.
But here what you
see is that I just
augmented the number
of training set points.
And what you see is now
the solution does change,
but not as much.
OK.
And you can kind of start to
see that there is something
going on a bit like this here.
OK.
So this one actually
looks pretty bad.
Let's try to do it once more.
OK.
So again, it does change a
lot, but not as much as before.
And you roughly
see that this guy
says that, here it should be
orange and here should be blue.
OK.
So that's kind of
what you expect.
The more points you get, the
better your solution would get.
And if I put hear all
the possible points, what
you will start to see is that
the closest point to any point
here will be a blue point.
OK.
So it will be perfect.
So if I ask you if this
is a good algorithm
or not, what would you say?
AUDIENCE: It's
overfitting the data.
LORENZO ROSASCO: It's kind
of a overfitting the data.
But it is not always
overfitting the data.
If the data are good, it's
a good idea to fit them.
OK.
But in some sense,
this algorithm
doesn't have a way
to prevent itself
to fall in love with the
data when there are very few.
And if you have very
few data points,
you start to just wiggle around,
become extremely unstable,
change your mind all the time.
If the data are
enough, it stabilizes,
and in some senses,
this setting,
we're fitting the data,
or as she's saying,
overfitting the data.
It's actually not a bad thing.
OK.
So this is what's going on here.
AUDIENCE: What do you
mean by overfitting?
LORENZO ROSASCO:
Fitting a bit too much.
So if you look here.
So here, if you look
what you're doing here,
you're always
fitting the data OK.
But here you're
doing nothing else.
And so if you have
few data points,
fitting the data is fine.
Sorry, if you have
many data points,
fitting the data is just fine.
If you have few data
points, by fitting them you,
in some sense,
overfit in the sense
that when you look
at new data points,
you have done a bit too much.
OK.
What you saw before,
that you get something
that is very good, because
it perfectly fits that,
but it's overfitting with
respect to the future.
Whereas here, the fitting
on the left-hand side
kind of reflects, not
too badly the fitting
on the right-hand side.
OK.
So the idea of
overfitting and stability
that came out in this
discussion are key.
OK.
If you want
everything we're going
to do in the next
three hours, understand
how you can prevent overfitting
and build a good way
to stabilize your algorithms.
OK.
So let's go back here.
This is going to be quick,
because if I ask you,
what is this?
What would you say?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHING]
LORENZO ROSASCO: So
the idea is that, when
you have a situation
like this, you're
still pretty much able to
say what's the right answer.
And what you're going
to do is that you're
going to move away from
just saying, what's
the closest point, and you
just look at a few more points.
You just don't look at one.
OK.
You look at, how many? boh?
"boh" is very
useful Italian word.
It means, I don't know.
So these algorithm-- it's
called the k nearest neighbor
algorithm, it's probably the
second simplest algorithm
you can think of.
It's kind of the same as before.
The notation here
is a bit boring,
but it's basically
saying, take the points.
Give them new points.
Check the distance
with everybody.
Sort it and take the first k.
OK.
If it's a
classification problem,
it's probably a good idea
to take an odd number for k,
so that you can then
just have voting.
And basically everybody votes.
Each vote counts one.
And somebody says blue,
somebody says orange,
and you make a decision.
OK.
Fair enough.
Well how does this work?
You can kind of imagine.
So what we have to do--
so for example here
we have this guy.
OK.
Now let's just put k--
well, let's make
this a bit smaller.
So we do 40.
Generate, plot, train.
[INAUDIBLE] test.
Plot.
OK.
Well we got a bit lucky, OK.
This is actually a good
dataset, because in some sense
there are no, what you
might call outliers.
There are no orange points that
really go and sit in the blue.
So I just want to show you a
bit about the dramatic effect
of this.
So I'm going to just
try to redo this one so
that we get the more--
yeah, this should do.
OK.
So this is nearest neighbor.
This is the solution you get.
It's not too horrible.
But, for example, you see that
it starts following this guy.
OK.
Now, what you can do is that you
can just go in and say, four.
Well, four's a bad idea.
Five.
You'd retrain them the same.
And all of a sudden it
just ignores this guy.
Because the moment that
you put more in, well,
you just realize that he's
surrounded by blue guys,
so it's probably just, his vote
just counts one against four.
OK.
And you can keep on going.
And the idea here is that
the more you make this big,
the more your solution
is going to be, what?
Well you say, it's
going to be good,
but it's actually not true.
Because if you start
to put k too big,
at some point all you're doing
is counting how many points you
have in class one,
counting how many points
you have in class two, and
always say the same thing.
OK.
So I'm going to put here, 20.
What you start to
see is that you
start to obtain a decision
boundary, which is simpler,
and simpler and simpler.
OK.
It looks kind of linear here.
What you will see is
that, suppose that now
I regenerate the data.
And you remember
how much it changed
before when I was using
nearest neighbor with just
k equal to 1.
So of course here, you
know, it's probabilistic.
OK.
So of course I'm going to get
a dataset like the one I just
showed you minutes ago, and
I had it as fast as possible.
Because if I pick
10, one is going
to look like that and nine
are going to look like this.
OK.
And when they look
like this, you
see, they kind of start
to have this kind of line,
like a decision boundary
with some twists.
But it's very simple.
OK.
And if at some point, if I
put k big enough-- that is,
the number of all points,
it won't change any more.
OK.
It will just be
essentially dividing
the sets in two equal parts.
So does that makes sense?
So would it make sense to
vote to make different votes?
Essentially, the idea is,
if the point is closest,
his vote should count more than
if a point is more far away?
Yes, absolutely.
Let's say here we're
making the simplest
thing in the world, the second
simplest thing in the world,
the third simplest
thing in the world.
It is doing that.
OK.
And you can see that you
can go pretty far with this.
I mean, it's simple, but
these are actually algorithms
that are used sometimes.
And what you do is that,
if you just look at this--
again, these I don't
want to explain too much.
If you've seen it
before, it's simple.
Otherwise it doesn't
really matter.
But the basic idea
here is that each vote
is going to be
between 0-- so, you
see here I put the distance
between the new point and all
the other points on
top of an exponential.
So the number I get is not
1, but it is between 0 and 1.
If the two points are close,
and the limits supposedly
are the same, it becomes a
0, and it counts exactly one.
If they're very far away,
these would be, say, infinity
and then we'd be close to 0.
So the closest you are,
the more you count.
If you want, you can
read it like this.
You're sitting on a new point,
and you put a zooming window.
Yeah, like a zooming
window of a certain size.
And you basically
check that everything
which is inside this
window will be closed.
And the more you go
farther away-- so
the window is like this.
And you deform the space
so that basically what
you say is, things
that are far away,
they're going to count less.
And if I move sigma
here, I'm somewhat
making my visual field, if
you want, larger or smaller,
around this one new point.
It's just a physical
interpretation
of what this is doing.
There are 15 other
ways of looking
at what the Gaussian is doing.
Voting, changing the weight
of the vote is another one.
OK.
Why the Gaussian here?
Well, because.
Just because.
You can use many, many others.
You can use, for
example, a hat window.
And this is part of
your prior knowledge,
how much you want to weight.
If you are in this kind of
low dimensional situation,
you might have good ways to
just look inside the data
and decide almost like doing
by a visual inspection.
Otherwise you have to trust
some more broad principles.
And it's again
back to the problem
of learning the
representation and deciding
how to measure
distance, which are
two phases of the same story.
OK.
And the other thing
you see is that, if you
start to do these games,
you might actually
add more parameters.
OK.
Because we start from
nearest neighbor,
which is completely
parameter-free,
but it was very unstable.
We added k.
We allow ourselves to go
from simple to complex,
from stability to overfitting.
But we introduced
a new parameter.
And so that's not an
algorithm any more.
It's a half algorithm.
A true algorithm is a
parameter-free algorithm
where I tell you how
you choose everything.
OK.
So if they just give
you something, say,
yeah, there's k, well,
how do you choose it?
OK.
It's not something you can use.
And here I'm adding sigma.
And again, you have to
decide how you use it.
OK.
And so that's what we
want to ask in a minute.
So before doing that,
just a side remark is--
we've been looking
at vector data.
OK.
And we were basically
measuring distance
through just the Euclidean
norm, OK, just the usual one,
or this version like
the Gaussian kernel
that somewhat
amplifies distances.
What if you have strings,
for example, or graphs?
OK.
Your data turns
out to be strings
and you want to compare them?
Say even if they're
binary strings,
there's no linear structure.
You cannot just sum them
up. the Euclidean distance
doesn't really make
a lot of sense.
But what you can
do is that as long
as you can define a
distance-- and say this one
would be the simplest one,
just the Hamming distance.
You just check entries,
and if they're the same,
you count one.
If they're different,
you count zero.
OK.
The moment you can define
a distance of your data,
then you can use this
kind of technique.
So this technique is pretty
flexible in that sense,
that whenever you can
give-- you don't need
a vectoral
representation, you just
need a way to measure,
say, similarity
or distances between things, and
then you can use this method.
OK.
So here I just mentioned
this, and that's
what most of these classes are
going to be, about vector data.
But this is one point where,
the moment you have k--
you can think of this case
sometimes as a similarity.
OK.
Similarity is kind of concept
that is dual to distances.
So if the similarity
is big, it's good.
The distance small is good.
OK.
And so here, if you have a way
to build the k or a distance,
then you're good to go.
And we're not going to
really talk about it,
but there's a whole
industry about how
you build this kind of stuff.
So we give restraints.
Maybe I want to say
that I should not only
look at the entry of a string,
but also the nearby entry when
I make the score
for that specific.
So maybe I shifted a value
of the string a little bit.
It's not right here.
It's in the next position over,
so that should come to bits.
So I want to do a
soft version of this.
OK.
Or maybe I have graphs, and
I want to compare graphs.
And I want to say that if
two graphs are close, then
I want them to have
the same label.
OK.
How do you do that?
The next big question is--
we introduced three parameters.
They look really nice,
because they kind of
allowed us to get more flexible
solutions to the problem
by choosing, for example, k
or the sigma in the Gaussian.
We can go from
overfitting to stability.
But then of course we have
to choose the parameter,
and we have to find good
ways to choose them.
And so there are a
bunch of questions.
So the first one is, well, is
there an optimal value at all?
OK.
Does it exist?
But if it does exist, I can go
try to estimate it in some way.
If it doesn't, well it
does not even make sense.
I just throw a random number.
I just say, k equals 4.
Why?
Just because.
OK.
So what do you think?
It exists or not?
What does it depend on?
Because that's
the next question.
What does it depend on?
Can we compute it?
OK.
So let's try to guess
one minute before we go
and check how we do this.
OK.
I have to choose it.
How do I choose it?
What does it depend on?
AUDIENCE: Size of this.
LORENZO ROSASCO: One thing
is the size of the dataset.
Because what we saw is that a
small k seems a good idea when
you have a lot of data, but
it seems like a bad idea
when you have few.
OK.
So it should depend.
It should be
something that scales
with n, the number of points,
and probably also the training
set itself.
But we want something that
works for all datasets,
say, in expectation.
So cardinality of
the training set
is going to be a main factor.
What else?
AUDIENCE: The smoothness
of the boundary.
LORENZO ROSASCO: The what?
AUDIENCE: The smoothness.
LORENZO ROSASCO: This
smoothness of the boundary.
Yeah.
So what he's saying is, if
my problem looks like this,
or if my problem
looks like this,
it looks like k
should be different.
In this case I can take
any arbitrary high k--
sorry, small k, I guess, or i.
It doesn't matter,
because whatever you do,
you pretty much
get the good thing.
But if you start doing
something like this,
then you want-- k is
enough, because otherwise
you just start to
blur everything.
And this is exactly
what he's saying.
If your problem is
complicated or it's easy.
OK.
And at the same
time, this is related
to the fact of how much noise
you might have in the data,
OK, how much flipping you
might have in your data.
If the problem is hard, then you
expect to need a different k.
OK.
So it depends on the
cardinality of the data,
and how complicated
is the problem?
How complicated it
is the boundary?
How much noise do I have?
OK.
So it turns out that
one thing you can ask
is, can we prove it?
OK.
Can we prove a theorem that
says that there is an optimal k,
and it really does depends
on this, on this quantities.
And it turns out that you can.
Of course, as always, to make a
theory or to make assumptions,
you have to work within a model.
And the model we want to
work on is the following.
You're basically
saying, this is the k
nearest neighbor solution.
So big k here is the
number of neighbors,
and this is hat because
it depends on the data.
And what I say here
is that I'm just
going to look at squared loss
error, just because it's easy.
And I'm going to look at the
regression problem, not just
this classification.
And what you do here
is that you take
expectation over all
possible input-output pairs.
So basically you say,
when I tried to do math,
I want to see what's ideal.
An ideally I want
a solution that
does well on future points.
OK.
So how do I do that?
I think the average error
over all possible points
in the future, x and y.
So this is the meaning of
this first expectation.
Make sense?
Yes?
No?
So if they fix y and x, this is
the error on a specific couple
input and output.
I give you the input.
I do f(kx) and then I check
if it's close or not to y.
But what I want to do if
I want to be theoretical
is to say, OK,
what I would really
like to be small is this error
over all possible points.
So I take the expectation,
not the one on the training
set, the one in the future.
And I take expectation
so that if points
are more likely
to be simple, they
will count more than points that
are less likely to be simple.
OK.
AUDIENCE: What was Es?
LORENZO ROSASCO: We haven't
got to that one yet.
OK.
So Exy is what I just said.
What is Es?
It's the expectation
over the training set.
Why do we need that?
Well because if we don't
put that expectation,
I'm basically telling you
what's the good k for this one
training set here.
Then I give you
another training set
and I get another one, which
is in some sense is good,
but it's also bad,
because we would
like to have a take-home
message that we
hold for all training sets.
And this is the simplest.
You say, for the
average training set,
this is how I should choose k.
That's what we want to do.
OK.
So the first expectation is
to measure error with respect
to the future.
The second
expectation is to say,
I want to deal with
the fact that I
have several potential
training sets appearing.
OK.
So in the next couple
of slides, this red dot
means that there
are computations.
OK.
And so I want to
do them quickly.
And the important thing of
this bit is, it's an exercise.
OK.
So this is an exercise
of stats zero.
OK.
So we don't want to
spend time doing that.
The important thing is going
to be the conceptual parts.
I'm going to go a bit
quickly through it.
So you start from
this, and you would
like to understand
if there exists--
so this is the quantity that
you would like to make small,
ideally.
You will never have
access to this,
but ideally, in the
optimal scenario,
you want k to make this small.
OK.
Now the problem is that you want
to essentially mathematically
study this m minimization
problem, but it's not easy,
because, how do you do this?
OK.
The dependence of this
function on k is complicated.
It's that equation
we had before, right?
So you kind of just
take the derivative
and set it equal to zero.
Let's keep on going into to.
So what we are at is,
these are the points
I would like to make small.
I would like to choose k so
that I can make this small.
I want to study this from a
mathematical point of view.
But I cannot just use what
you're doing in calculus,
which is taking a derivative
and setting it equal to zero,
because the dependence of these
two k, which is my variable,
it's complicated.
OK.
So we go a bit of a round way.
We turn out to be
pretty universal.
And this is what
we are going to do.
First of all, we assume
a model for our data.
And this is just for
the sake of simplicity.
OK.
I can use a much
more general model.
But this is the model.
I'm going to say that my y
are just some fixed function
of star plus some noise.
OK.
And the noise is zero
mean and variance sigma
square for all entries.
OK.
This is the simplest model.
It's a Gaussian
regression model.
So one thing I'm doing,
and this is like a trick
and you can really
forget it, but it just
makes life much easier is that
I take the expectation over xy
and a condition here.
OK.
The reason why you
do this is just
to make the math a bit easier.
Because basically now, if
you put this expectation out,
and you look just
at these quantities,
you're looking at
everything for fixed x.
And these just become a real
number, OK, not the function
anymore.
So you can use normal calculus.
You have a real-valued
function and you can just
use the usual stuff.
OK.
Again, I'm going to going
a bit quickly over this
because it doesn't
really matter.
So this ingredient one.
This is observation two.
Observation three
is that you need
to introduce an object
between the solution you
get in practice and
this ideal function.
What is this?
It's this kind of, what
is called the expectation
of my algorithm.
What you do is that--
in my algorithm
what I do here is
that I put Yi, i OK,
just the label of
my training set.
And the label are noisy.
But this is an ideal object
where you put the true function
itself, and you just average
the value of the true function.
Why do I use this?
Because I want to
get something which
is in between this
f-star and this f-hat.
So if you put k big enough--
so if you have enough points,
this is going to be--
sorry, if you take
k small enough--
so this is closer to
f-star than my f-hat,
OK, because you
get no noisy data.
And what I want to do--
oops.
What I want to do is that I
want to plug it in the middle
and split this error in two.
And this is what I do.
OK.
If you do this, you can check
that you have a square here.
You get two terms.
One simplifies, because of
this assumption on the noise,
and you get these two terms.
OK.
And the important thing
is these two terms
are-- one is the comparison
between my algorithm
and its expectation.
So that's exactly what
we called a variance.
OK.
And one is the comparison
between the value
of the true function
here, and the value
of this other function.
Sorry, this should be--
oh yeah.
This is the
expectation, which is
my ideal version of my
algorithm, the one that has
access to the noiseless labels.
OK.
It's what you call a bias.
It's basically because,
instead of using
the exact value of the
function, you blur it
a bit by averaging out.
OK.
You see here, instead of using
the value of the function,
you average out a
few nearby values.
So you're making
it a bit dirtier.
The question now is, how
would these two quantities
depend on k?
How this quantity depends
on k and how this quantity
depends on k.
OK.
And then by putting
this together,
we'll see that we have a
certain behavior of this,
and a certain behavior of this.
And then balancing
this out, we'll
get what the optimal
value looked like.
And this is going to
be all useless from--
so these are going
to be interesting
from a conceptual perspective.
We're going to learn
something, but we'll still
have to do something practical,
because nothing of this
you can measure in practice.
OK.
So the next question
would be, now that we
know that it exists and
it depends on this stuff,
how can we actually
approximate it in practice?
And cross-validation is going
to pop out of the window.
OK.
But this is the
theory that shows you
that this would help
proving a theory that
shows that cross-validation is
a good idea, in a precise sense.
The take-home message
is, by making this model
and using this as an
intermediate object,
you split the error in two, and
you start to be able to study.
And what you get is
basically the following.
This term, by basically using--
so we assume that the data--
I didn't say that,
but that's important.
We assume that the data are
independent with each other.
OK.
And by using that, you get
these results right away,
essentially using the
fact that the variance
of the sum of the
independent variable
is the sum of the variances.
You get these
results in one line.
OK.
And basically what this shows
is that, if k gets big--
so variance is another
word for the stability.
OK.
So if you have a big variance,
things will vary a lot.
It will be unstable.
So what you see here is exactly
what we observe in the plot
before.
If k was big, things are
not changing as much.
If k was small, things
were changing a lot.
OK.
And this is the one equation
that shows you that.
OK.
And if you just look at
that, it would just tell you,
the big is better.
Big, respect to what?
To the noise.
OK.
If there is a lot of noise,
I should make it bigger.
If there's more noise,
I can make it smaller.
But the point is
that we saw before is
that the problem
of putting k large
was that we were forgetting
about the problem.
We're just getting something
that was very stable
but could be potentially very
bad, if my function was not
that simple.
OK.
This is a bit harder to
study mathematically.
OK.
This is a calculation
that I show you
because you can do it yourself
in like 20 minutes, or less.
This one takes a bit more.
But he can get the hunch
on how it looks like.
And the basic idea is
what we already said.
If k is small, and the points
are close enough, instead
of f-star x, we are
thinking of f-star Xk, Xi.
And the i is closing off.
OK.
Now if we start to
put k bigger, we
start to blur that prediction by
looking at many nearby points.
But here there is no noise.
OK.
So that sounds like a bad idea.
So we expect the
error in that case
to be either increasing, or at
least flat with respect to k.
So when we take k larger,
we're blurring this prediction,
and potentially make it
far away from the true one.
OK.
And you can make this
statement precise.
You can prove it.
And if you will prove it,
it's basically that you have--
what happened?
You have linear dependence.
So the error here is linearly
increasing or polynomially
increasing-- in fact I don't
remember-- with respect to k.
OK.
So the reason why
I'm showing you
this, skipping
all these details,
is just to give you a feeling
of the kind of computation
that answered the question
if there is a optimal value
and what it depends on.
And then at this point,
once you get this,
you start to see
this kind of plot.
And typically here I
put them the wrong way.
But here you
basically say, I have
this one function
I wanted to study,
which is the sum
of two functions.
I have this, and I have this.
OK.
And now to study
the minimum, I'm
basically going to
sum them up and see
what's the optimal value
to optimize this too.
And the k that optimized this
is exactly the optimal k.
And you see that the optimal
k will behave as we expected.
OK.
So here, one
ingredient is missing.
And it's just missing
because I didn't put it in,
which is the number of points.
OK.
It's just because I
didn't renormalize things.
OK.
It should be a 1 over n here.
It's just that I
didn't renormalize.
OK.
But you announced it, and
it's good, because it's true.
There should be
a 1 over n there.
But the rest is
what we expected.
OK.
In some sense what we expect
is that if my problem is
complicated, I
need the smaller k.
If there is a lot of
noise, I need a bigger k.
And depending on the
number of points,
which would be in
the numerator here,
I can make a bigger or a larger.
k.
OK.
This plot is fundamental because
it shows some property which
is inherent in the problem.
And the theorem that
somewhat is behind it--
intuition I've been saying,
repeating over and over,
which is this intuition that you
cannot trust the data too much.
And there is the optimal amount
of trust you can of your data
based on certain assumptions.
OK.
And in our case, the assumption
where this kind of model.
So little calculation
I'll show you quickly,
grounds this intuition into
a mathematical argument.
OK.
All right.
So we spent quite a
bit of time on this.
In some sense, from a
conceptual point of view,
this is a critical idea.
OK.
Because it's behind
pretty much everything.
This idea of, how much you
can trust or not of the data.
Of course here, as we said,
this has been informative,
hopefully.
But you cannot
really choose this k,
because you would need
to know the noise,
but especially to know how
to estimate this in order
to minimize this quantity.
So in practice what
you can show is,
you can use what is
called cross-validation.
And in effect,
cross-validation is
one of a few other
techniques you can use.
And the idea is that you
don't have access [AUDIO OUT]
but you can show that if you
take a bunch of data points,
you split them in two, you
use half for the training
as you've always done, and you
use the other half as a proxy
for this future data.
Then by minimizing the k--
taking the k that minimized the
error on this so-called holdout
set, then you can prove
it's as good as if you
could have access to this.
OK.
And it's actually
very easy to prove.
You can show that if
you're just split in two,
and you minimize the
error in second half--
you do what is called the
holdout cross-validation-- it's
as good as if you'd
had access to this.
OK.
So it's optimal in a way.
Now, the problem with this
is that we are only looking
at the area and expectation.
And what you can check is that
if you look at higher order
statistics, say that
variance of your estimators
and so on and so forth,
what you might get
is that by splitting in two,
[AUDIO OUT] big is fine.
In practice the
difference is small,
you might get that the way
you split might matter.
You might have bad luck and
just split in a certain way.
And so there is a whole
zoology of ways of splitting.
And the basic one
is, say, split--
this is, for example,
the simplest.
OK.
Split in a bunch of groups.
k-fold or v-fold
cross-validation.
Take one group out of the time.
OK.
And do the same trick.
You know, you train here
and calculate the error here
for different k's.
Then you do the same
here, do the same here,
do the same here.
Sum the errors
up, renormalizing,
and then just choose
the k that minimizes
this new form of error.
And if the data there are
small, small, small, then
typically this set
will become very small.
And then delimited, it becomes
one, the leave one out error.
OK.
What you do is
that you literally
leave one out,
train on the rest,
get there for all the
values of k in this case.
Put it back in, take another one
out, and repeat the procedure.
Now the question that I
had 10, 15 minutes ago was,
how do you choose v?
OK.
Shall I make this two?
So I just do one
split like this?
Or shall I make it n,
so I do leave one out?
And as far as I
know there is not
a lot of theory
that would support
an answer to this question.
And what I know is mostly what
you can expect intuitively,
which is, if you have
a lot of data points--
what does it mean a lot?
I don't know.
If you have two million,
10,000, I don't know.
If you have a big dataset,
typically splitting in two,
or maybe doing just random
splits is stable enough.
What does it mean?
That you try, and you
look at how much it moves.
Whereas if you have say--
you know, I don't know
if it even exists,
the implication like, you
know, a few years ago there
were micro-reapplication where
you would have 20, 30 inputs,
and you have 20 dimensions.
And then in that case, you
really don't do much splitting.
If you have 20, for example,
you try to leave one out
and it's the best you can do.
And it's already very
unstable and sucks.
OK.
So in this case, there
is work to be done.
I mean, as far as I know,
that's the state of things.
OK.
So we introduced a class
of very simple algorithms.
They seem to be
pretty reasonable.
They seem to allow us,
provided that we have a way
to measure distances
or similarity,
to go from simple to complex.
And we have some
kind of theory that
tells us what is the optimal
value of a parameter,
a kind of practical procedure to
actually choose it in practice.
OK.
Are we done?
Is that all?
do we need to do anything else?
What's missing here?
One thing that is
missing here is
that most of the intuition
we developed so far
are really related
to low dimension.
OK.
And here, very quickly, if
you just do a little exercise
where you try to say
how big is a cube
that covers 1% of the volume of
a bigger cube of a unit length?
OK.
So the big cube is volume 1.
The length of that is just 1.
And it ask you, how
big is this, if it
has to cover 1% of the volume?
It's really to check that these
are just going to be a dth-root
where d is the
dimension of the cube.
And this is the shape
of the dth-root.
OK.
So if you're in low
dimension, basically, 1%
is intuitively small
within the big cube.
But as soon as you're go
in higher dimensional, what
you see is that the length of
the edge of the little cube
that has to cover 1% of the
volume becomes very close to 1,
almost immediately.
It's this curve going up.
OK.
What does it mean?
That if you say, our
intuition is, well, 1%.
It's a pretty small volume.
If I just took the neighbors
in 1%, they're pretty close,
so they should have
the same label.
Well, in dimension
10, it's everything.
OK.
So our intuition-- now you
can say that probably there
is something wrong with my way
of thinking of volume, sure.
But the problem is that
we have to rethink a bit
how you think of dimensions and
similarity in high dimension,
because things that are
obvious low dimensional
start to be very complicated.
OK.
And the basic idea is that
this neighbor technique just
looks at what's
happening in one region.
But what you hope to do is
that if your function actually
has some kind of
global properties--
so, say for example a sign
is the simplest example
of something which is global,
because the value here
and the value here
are very much related.
And then it goes up
and it's the same.
And then it goes down.
So if you know
something like this,
the idea is that you
can borrow strength
from points which are far away.
In some sense the function
has some similar properties.
And so you want to go
from a local estimation
to some form of
global estimation.
OK.
And instead of making
a decision based
only on the neighbors
of the points,
you might want to use points
which are potentially far away.
OK.
And this seems to be like a good
idea in high dimensions where
the neighboring points might
not give enough information .
And that's kind
of what's called,
curse of dimensionality.
OK.
So what I want to do next--
we can take a break here--
is discussing least squares
and kernel least squares.
OK.
But what we're going
to do is that we're
going to take a linear
model of our data,
and then we are
going to try to see
how you can estimate and learn.
And we're going to look
at bit of the computation
and a bit of the statistical
idea underlying this model.
And then we're going to play
around in a very simple for way
to extend from a linear
model to a non-linear model
and actually make
it non-parametric.
I'll tell you what
non-parametric means.